I'm here to talk today about I actually
regret the name of my talk a little bit
advanced Design Systems considerations
mostly because it's a mouthful but also
I mean advanced less like advanced math
and more like advanced osteoarthritis or
something right I want to talk about
what the work is once you convince
everyone at your company to use your
design system and once you're done
building out all the name-brand
components so I work with stripe on our
design system team we're two designers
two engineers and a manager for a total
of five people and I just found out from
Wikipedia I promise this is true that
stripe is over 2,000 employees now so
that's a heck of a ratio one to five
that's the goal right for design systems
their leverage dedicated team of four
individual contributors can abstract and
maintain the design language and
technical implementation for a component
library for 2,000 people how's it going
it's fine it's good it's I think I think
it does a good job it's not magic
despite my most sincere efforts I was a
great talk by the way
I think we create more value than we
remove I believe in our goals and I
think my co-workers and teammates on
this team are some of the most
thoughtful and capable people to be
working on this problem in existence so
we've done nifty work on accessible
color systems applying a lot of magic to
choosing one and we've made building
consistent stripes looking interfaces a
little bit easier and we have some or
another version of just about every
component that you can think of often to
our detriment this is massive work
design systems are hardly a new concept
you don't look much further than an old
NASA graphics standard manual from 60s
and 70s to find cool cool design systems
but there are very new challenges
especially technical ones that compound
on the old challenges the complexity is
multiplied Robert Rendell recently wrote
an essay that compared design systems to
the idea of a hyper object and that idea
resonated with my team very strongly and
with me he is referencing a book by
James bridle called the new Dark Age it
says a hyper object is I'm going to read
to you a thing that surrounds us
envelops and entangles us that is
literally too big to see in its entirety
mostly we perceive hyper objects through
their influence on other things a
melting ice sheet a dying sea the
buffeting of a transatlantic flight
hyper objects happen everywhere at once
but we can only experience them in the
local environment
in fact they stand outside both our
perception and our measurement they
exist without us because they are so
close and get so hard to see they defy
our ability to describe them rationally
and to master or overcome them in
traditional sense climate change is a
hyper object but so is nuclear radiation
evolution and the Internet I agree
that's very dramatic design systems are
not climate change they do often feel
like sneakily complex systems like no
single person can hold the whole thing
in their head anymore it's like trying
to figure out what shape the crop circle
is from inside the cornfield you can
spend an incredible amount of time
thoughtfully tackling an issue only to
zoom out zoom out again just to see that
you're working in a tiny subsection of a
tiny subsection of your design system
and that idea really sums up a lot of
the work that's involved in the second
and third waves there need a bit put
into a design system it's all about
trying to make the entire thing useful
while all also making any arbitrary
subset equally useful do not require
each person each user of the system to
hold the entire thing in their heads
there's of course lots of information
that exists on how to create a design
system there books and tutorials and how
to jump past a lot of the difficult pain
points that's not my focus here but I
certainly would be lost without all that
prior art so I'd be happy to recommend
some of that if you want to chat later
you first get started on design system
you have some fundamentally different
and often opposite goals is when you're
trying to level up an existing design
system when you first get started you
want to make lots of new components your
goal is coverage you want to maximize
the number of designs that are possible
with your system
you work on selling people to use it
versus rolling their own components or
doing one-off designs and you actively
seek real estate in your applications to
see what you can replace with a cleaner
design system version of the thing you
want people to be excited about using
your design system once you hit critical
mass of adoption your goals are to start
your goals start shifting pretty quickly
you worry more about keeping the system
healthy and alive not about selling its
value directly you fight to make sure
you don't become too dated but for the
most part he hit a stage where your goal
is to blend into the platform one of my
favorite 2019 goals on my team at stripe
was that another team would announce a
conversion of their application to our
design system without thanking us at the
end of the email our goal was to become
part of the expected platform rather
than an exciting tool that people have
to think a lot about we it happened is
both frustrating and very exciting
another surprising change in the second
phase is that where you once judge
yourself on how many components you
added in a quarter you start valuing the
opposite whether it's crafty old
components that never did the right
thing anyway or super specific
components that could probably be
achieved by customizing generic ones you
quickly appreciate the things that
reduce the system complexity your
primary goal stays the same as poor
though it's to provide a system that
adheres to your values so the resulting
you eyes adhere to your values really
common design system thing I see
sometimes even attached to two goals for
your business metrics or something as a
desire to add components in perpetuity I
think this happens for two reasons first
is the idea that the more components you
make the faster it will make developers
and the more useful the library will be
I think this assumption comes from a
good place but I've never seen it play
out in practice a very solid core of
atomic components can be well understood
and proposed and recomposed by your
users and unlimited permutations you
build them well you won't have to fit
new ideas into old components the faulty
assumption is that having a component
that does something close to what you
want makes you faster well when I think
back to the most frustrating waste of
time in my career it's almost always in
trying to
figure some mega components to do one
thing that it wasn't quite designed to
do so fight for a cut atomic components
doesn't mean your applications shouldn't
make their own logic list complex non
non atomic components that they share
between the app but it just means that
those components probably shouldn't live
in your design system the other reason I
see engineers continuously add
components is that they actually have a
secret desire to rewrite the things that
they don't own at the company I know
this sounds like a conspiracy theory and
I'm sorry for that but I'm gonna keep
going it does follow a pretty natural
evolution first you fix all the buttons
and then you fix all the menus and tabs
and cards and eventually you're out of
kind of the atomic seeming components
you still want things to look better and
so instead of stopping you find yourself
searching for any patterns that are
reused more than one time to turn into
components oh here's a person card and a
detailed person card we could kind of
smash those together and retake that
land suddenly they're pretty business
specific and pretty application specific
and then you want the pricing page to
look nicer but it's so entrenched in the
old stack that no one will touch it so
eventually throw off all pretenses of
component reuse and you build the
pricing banner component throw it in the
design system and then replace it so you
don't have to look at it anymore we have
I I have these urges everyone has these
urges but I'd recommend you work these
things out or get organizationally
rather than declaring manifest destiny
on other teams technical debt you'll
like your design system more in the end
I want to dig back into the first point
I brought up there though there's this
common perception of design systems that
they're intended to increase efficiency
and I think this is entirely wrong but I
think efficiency is a secondary goal of
a design system the primary goal of a
design system in my opinion is to uphold
your values design systems are so you
can ensure that when a developer is
making trade-offs to ship something
before a looming deadline that that
thing falls off the chopping block that
the thing that falls off the chopping
block is an accessibility a performance
or visual consistency or all attention
to detail design systems are tools to
uphold the quality of your product even
in the face of consuming teams that
aren't paying particular attention
quality a design system is successful
when someone can throw together equip a
quick application and why while that
application may fail to achieve the
specific business goals it still upholds
the values that are otherwise left
behind in crunch time it's accessible
consistent performant and whatever else
you've decided is important to you one
of my first actionable recommendations
is to fight against the wrong contextual
specificity and components it's very
common to end up with a lot of similar
components that often do almost the same
thing and maybe even describe the
context that they're used in icon button
icon action icon menu icon all our
seemingly icons it's also common to
recognize this complexity and then move
everything over into a single component
and you end up with kind of like an
explosion of props that all do something
very specific only for one use case you
can't always avoid one of these traps
but we want to move in a direction that
tries to allow the context to dictate
the differences not a bunch of problem
so let's see if we can contextually
create a button icon which is the one at
the top there without actually needing a
component like that you notice in this
example from the stripe dashboard we
have two icon types visible one icon
inside the button and one outside
they're mostly the same but the one
inside the button is 12 pixels and the
one outside the button is 14 pixels
that's your different I mean they're
also different icons but relax
I'd expect many people's first
iterations to look something like this
we add a prop directly to button to
declare the type of the icon we'd like
it to contain icon equals gear you can
imagine it puts a gear into the icon but
then we recognize that in order to
change anything about the icon
we'd actually need to duplicate all the
props from icon onto button so if we
wanted to change the size we'd have to
like add an icon size prop there or an
icon style prop to grab them all that's
possible but not pretty it stands out to
me that button also must now import icon
whether you use it or not so let's try
another approach to try to separate them
put it directly inside the component
like this so now we put an actual icon
inside an actual button this is great
and we could be done but like I said
sadly icons are 14 pixels by default and
the icons inside of a button are 12
pixels by default we could make a rule
that says all developers must remember
to change the size to 12 when they put
an icon in a button but we all know how
well that would go our complexity of our
system is leaking out we have a
dependency between button icons that
that we're not describing well so rather
than require each developer to remember
this on their own we could make a new
component that's mostly an icon maybe it
even wraps an icon but sets the button
defaults instead of the regular icon
defaults in this case being 12 pixels
but we're back to button icon again this
is this is where we started this is the
hyper object in action the user of our
system has to know about all the quirks
involved in icons versus button icons to
know that they want to put an icon into
a button and they have to actually use
the different type of icon not an icon
itself and they have to learn the
specific thing about the system they
have to hold a lot more in their heads
in order to use it also what happens if
someone doesn't know about button icon
and just jams an icon in there anyways
then you are mixing 14 pixel until pixel
icon Sheen one approaches all this that
we could take somewhere in the middle of
the two solutions is allow a regular
icon to be passed into the button but
make it a prop rather than something
that goes into the children the button
can safely override the
add the 12:12 pixel size before
injecting it into the the children
inside the code this was initially
pretty attractive to me but I think it
still leaks complexity back out to the
user we still have the initial problem
where we have to add special icon props
like icon position starts to be an issue
here and we still don't prevent someone
who doesn't know about these props from
just Jemmy an icon directly into the
children we can fix that problem and
kind of paper over a few more by getting
rid of children entirely
which is a technique that is often used
we can replace the functionality with a
label prop it's not it's not pretty but
it feels like it probably meets our
goals in this specific case but maybe
not many others I don't feel great about
this it feels like button just got a
whole lot uglier and using entire system
feels less regular I think as a user I
might be compelled to just skip using
the design system button and kind of
roll my own and make one myself my
opinion we have to work backwards from
the goal state users can reason really
well with our original solution it's
actually not our original solution but
the second solution and just put an icon
inside the button you don't need to know
anything about the system in order to
write this this is just composing two
atomic pieces possibly the only two you
know and if it did what we wanted this
subsystem would feel closed we have to
just solve for the problem the icon
should be smaller when it's inside of a
button how do we do that
it seems like we have to either make
icon aware of when it's in a button we
had to make button aware of it when it
contains an icon so let's try the ladder
inside of a button you don't have to
actually read this too closely we can
enumerate each of the contexts that it
knows about to try to render something
different and adapt to its surroundings
so we have this kind of thing that I'm
abstract anout called is in button is
this icon in a button this is not ideal
if we can be rendered into multiple
things there's this combat auric logic
of am i in a card and a button and a
something and it just explodes also like
are we doing upwards tree traversal in
order to determine that it seems all
pretty plainly not nice so here's our
goal state again just to try to recenter
s let's try flipping who knows about who
maybe we can make the button find and
change icons that are inside of it to be
a smaller size this is actually pretty
similar to our real first idea where we
just added an icon prop and and that
felt pretty natural but it's not a great
solution for the same reason because the
button needs to know about and possibly
even directly depend on icon you get
some weird code like this where you have
to import icon from the button and then
you have to search down into the
children to see if it contains icons
like it says clearly maybe not a very
tenable solution it's about as ugly of a
company as I could think of actually I
know I can be less obviously silly and
write some CSS this is better but it's
still pretty sad because now regardless
of whether we need an icon or not every
time we pull in button we also have to
pull in all or part of icon they become
someone clear that trying to resolve
this is our primary objective sorry our
primary objective is to decouple these
two components neither should depend on
the other so we want to create
relationships without encoding strict
dependencies this is a theme this is
pretty similar to the goal in
denormalization in databases so two
models share a common value so we can
either have them fully depend on each
other be in the same row as each other
or we can create a reference to a shared
value kind of like a foreign key to
solve this we've added a new concept to
our design system and encapsulate the
same idea it's a shared value these we
call these values tokens but you don't
have to it's certainly an overloaded
term it's a tiny shared dependency that
holds a value remembers the context that
it's set in in this case it determines
the size of an icon
either component is free to write or
read from the value or stop doing
anything with the value at all in this
specific case we have icon size token
it's 14 pixels by default icon we'd use
this value to determine its width and
height and button would override this
value for any of its children so it
looks like we have an icon inside of a
button and it's going to read the value
through the context button and see that
it's 12 so this is our solution
it also means that you can delete button
entirely from your application and
things keep working or you can delete
icons from your application maybe you
have a weirdly named token but
everything stays working and neither
file depends on on the other we still
have a directed a cyclical dependency
graph of the old dag for my graph nerds
out there so these are now atomic
components again our final solution
doesn't look very interesting to an end
user that's the goal
it's exactly this first most natural
idea that we had before but now thanks
to the in token the the token that
encodes the relationship of a shared
value user doesn't have to worry about
the icon being the wrong size in the
wrong spot and they also don't have to
bring along their own icon just whenever
they import button they only carry
tokens they encode relationships without
creating strict dependencies our goal in
separating buttons and icons like this
is to make sure that each component
isn't reliant on the other the token
idea is just one illustrative part not
some Silver Bullet of creating system
that doesn't leak complexity all over
the users a theme that arises when you
think about these concepts is
decentralization if your goal is to be
able to avoid needing the entire system
in your head and it makes sense that
each centralization becomes a critical
property of things you add to the system
but centralization is difficult to avoid
and it can be very sneaky and and bite
you from all over the place consider the
button and icon example from before we
have two totally disparate atomic
components and just trying to make the
icon size twelve pixels inside of a
button causes or create a dependency in
one or both directions which is super
rough there are other pretty common feet
guns that aren't super obvious as well
configuration stands out as a major
point of centralization we have a big
system that all functions independently
and we often Jam every option for the
independent pieces into a giant JSON
file at the top this points at a flaw of
the way we think about configure a
configuration in my opinion it's a
top-down global store of variables to be
set by the consumer of your system we've
all been warned about
local variables before I'm sure
configuration is often contextual
configuration begets more configuration
what we're really trying to achieve when
we make something configurable is giving
control over something to the
implementer luckily there are patterns
for this other than just shared global
constants on our team we've lean into
the idea of inversion of control for
configuration we use exportable tokens
that same token system we use before and
they can be overwritten at each level of
application hierarchy kind of like
context can be you can declare your
configurable tokens where they're used
rather than at the top this leans into
our decentralization goals imagine
instead of setting a global brand color
you imported the brand color token from
the color's module and overrode it or
aliased it and then any child component
that used brand color we get your
updated value much like the 12 pixels
example the configuration becomes code
but that code can live anywhere not just
at the very top theming in general is
the best use case that we've seen for
this we can start with a color set
that's imported and overridden and
remixed all throughout the app and the
equivalent centralized config would be
thousands of lines of JSON here another
thing that you can kind of inject into
this idea of in version control is
internationalization it's a great
pattern for internationalization because
my rough advice and and I do a lot of
work with the internationalization is
that your application already has to
solve internationalization problems so
rather than solve them again just cede
control back out to the application each
user of your design system may be using
different localization tools and
embedding internationals
internationalized formatters and message
bundles and doing that also in your
design system could bloat it to unusable
levels you want to avoid creating a
parallel internationalization system
that's used in the application this is
good for performance and just
cleanliness so it's not a huge leap to
say that instead of rendering
internationalized text as the default
label for your button that you'd use
approach that we've been discussing to
allow applications to override the
formatters to mash ones that they are to
use
the key to a well internationalized
design system is really just being a
highly composable design system that
gives control over to a well
internationalized application last kind
of idea that I want to talk about is one
that we're kind of playing with right
now still we are looking to mimic some
of the patterns in swiss blue.i from
apple and there's been some interesting
fallout from that one interesting
property of Swift UI
if you're used to modern JavaScript
frameworks is that you nearly always
start with single root level component
rather than the somewhat more common
higher-order components model where
components wrap other components wrap
other components they call these
blank-slate base components of view and
so we do two but you could call it a box
or a component or something whatever you
want another property of Swift UI is
that an inorder set of modifications
called the modifiers surprisingly that
is run on that base component so you can
think of that as a set of
transformations
so what are we transforming in our react
brains these are just transforms on the
children or the props or the state or
the attributes that you know the kind of
for things that you have control over
and in this example we first take the
content we add the padding and then we
add a background color and then we add a
foreground color then we change the font
it's a procedural which feels kind of
weird but also maybe kind of cool and
just calling on this collet we call it
on the content itself we just return the
content with the dot padding on it I
know it seems cool so we tried it out we
kind of put a similar idea into a react
component the view component starts with
no children or state of props or
attributes and each modifier has a job
to add modify or remove one or many of
those things when you think about this
you can actually drop frameworks out of
the picture they're mostly irrelevant
until you're done building up the set of
those children state props and
attributes but this happens after all
the modifiers run you can use your
framework of choice to render that
actual set this is kind of magic for a
few different reasons the first is that
you have an audible list of transforms
that you add to your component and makes
building up a component really easy to
observe first we had some text then we
had a CSS class that we had
the Candler then we update some state
instead of sharing a button component
itself you can actually share just the
list of modifiers that a button has that
means components are always only one
level deep which vibes really well with
our goals around sports dependency
graphs between components and we're just
passing around little groups of these
little transforms now this concept is a
little easier to understand when you see
it we were able to put together a little
modifier step through a viewer the top
button with hello world in it is the end
state and then the each check box turns
on a different modifier and then you can
kind of eventually see that come through
the projector contrast hurts up a little
bit but maybe it's filled still it's
enough this is the array of modifiers
that we're kind of turning on or off
second reason this is magic is the bit I
mentioned before pretty much none of
this has anything to do with a framework
until you need to render the actual
component so you're just generating and
transforming the configuration for a
future component then you have to turn
your children state props attributes
into a rendered component so nearly all
components can be described as a set of
modifiers instead of as unique
components and that means your design
system components can be described
outside the bounds of a single UI
framework means we can write a renderer
and react it also means we could write a
renderer insult or view or even
something like a sketch or figma plugin
to automatically get our components into
a design tool from code this is a
powerful idea there's still a bunch of
work to write these renders it's not a
panacea and some things like a date
picker so far have been a little too
interactive to get in this magic
framework agnostic way but if design
systems are about upholding the values
of your company it's unlikely that those
values will change just because
something is more trendy than react now
you should build up a system that
encodes your values and you should write
a renderer that displays them in the
cool frameworks that your teams want you
to implement even if those frameworks
change over time so what a success look
like I have no idea of course we're not
even close to success we have to phone
number inputs I don't know why we're
hardly at the fully baked stage of any
of these ideas
I want to discuss them with you for that
reason but it definitely feels like
there's a thread throughout all the
solutions and problems that we're facing
Design Systems are hyper objects so we
need to make design systems that contain
closed subsystems that are
comprehensible that starts with making
atomic components that favor extremely
small dependency trees an atomic
component is its own complete closed sub
system and any arbitrary set of those
subsystems can be composed into
increasingly larger closed sub systems
that's a sentence decisions are
decentralized components are tied
together via ceding control to each
other and based on the order of their
composition your values are deeply
connected and encoded into the technical
implementation but not tied directly to
the framework of the week a successful
design system can describe intent
without needing react more than anything
though a good design system prioritizes
upholding values over everything else it
facilitates the increased likelihood
that applications are built with it are
also share those same values Thanks
[Applause]